so listen i got i got a million
questions i want to start with um i know
how hard it is to get brad pitt to sign
on to a movie yeah you know he gets
offered every script in the industry
with those um for people that don't
realize like the script comes with we're
ready to pay you please make the movie
um so what is it like
like how did you convince him to do this
was the fact that you've known him for
so long like talk a little bit about
getting um you know it was i i was as
shocked as you are right now you know
yes i've known him for
for a long long time but to get brad
pitt on a movie is like um it's like um
lightning in a bottle and so
when
kelly brought me bullet train and i read
it and we were like oh i'm okay i'm in
i'm in kelly i'm in okay we'll figure
out the characters like okay um ladybug
it's brad it's got to be brad and you
know talking to samford panics they had
you know done a bunch of movies with
brad together he's like we can do it we
can get him we can get him and i'm like
can we and it was a lot of anxiety uh
sending it over i i just was like um
is it is he gonna want to do it you know
it's so crazy and wacky and irreverent
and i don't know and i'm like i don't i
just don't want to waste his time and
stamford's like i'm doing it i'm doing
it so sanford said it like i wasn't even
necessarily ready and then boom they got
it brad's uh
you know threw the script to the wolf
and that's how he tells the story and
he's like he was in like he was laughing
his ass off he saw a ladybug he's like i
can play this guy oh and it's david um i
want to do something with him um
and i have a window this feels great and
so he called me and said um leech i
think we're doing this thing you want to
do it let's do it and um it was like
really kind of a surreal moment you know
as good of a friend as he is it's still
surreal like oh now you know i've been
working with brad for so long
supporting him as a stunt double
building characters now he's going to
build this character that supports me as
a filmmaker
it's pretty awesome also once he signs
on the picture is like an immediate go
yeah you know like it's i'm sure
everyone at the studio everyone is like
oh what this needs to happen what are we
doing
correct you know it is more that is one
of those things where it's like oh now
we're not kind of looking for a
production window it's like when can
brad make it brad wants to brad's we're
going to make it now
great we're making it now like you know
forces mobilize and so it is one of
those watershed moments in um
uh
in a filmmaking process where you get
your lead talent and um
everything's activated and it it's
double that when it's brad one of the
things that i just can't believe and i
don't think anyone will believe after
they watch the movie is i would say i
don't know what the percentage is but
like 90 something percent of this movie
was shot on a sony backlot in culver
city yeah not even a backlot per se like
this inside a stage
sure oh you know we um
we had uh
we were hoping at some point that
coveted during pre-production like kobe
would lighten up and we could get to
japan and so there was part of me was
like
oh
i was really bummed when we were we
realized we're never gonna get in like
this is like uh pipe dream and again now
you're talking about the windows already
you know the train is already rolling so
to speak no pun intended but there's a
window brad's doing it during this time
so it's like okay what's the version of
this movie where we
you know try some of this new virtual
production technology you know
mandalorian style stuff so
met with visual effects met with
cinematographer um
jonathan sela and we started to research
this idea of like let's have led screens
outside of the train
um can we shoot plate material
in japan with a remote crew
before pre-production which we did
augment the plates stitch them together
create some digital plates heightened
stuff get this all done in the next
eight weeks before we step foot on a
train and um
the the answer was no [ __ ] way
exactly and then
as movies happen it's just like of
course there's a way
film crews are the most resourceful and
creative people on the planet from my
experience and um
the everyone just mobilized and like you
know mike brazelton incredible vfx
supervisor who worked at d neg
for years and um
you know came onto this project as his
first supervising role like he took the
reins and like
made that that stuff happen outside the
walls and
um that was you know piece one of the
puzzle the other was like platforms like
we're telling stories on these different
platforms and journeys so david
schuneman the production designer
came up with this ingenious idea to
re-clad make it a modular platform
and so we had different
some of the structures were
structural some of the poles were
structural some of them were facades
right and we could remove them and take
them and re-clad them reclad walls put
in set walls to make this one
platform feel like a journey of seven
platforms
and it could be redressed within a day
or two because of our schedule
uh and again like just the ingenuity of
it all like you know um
it still blows me away like what art
department construction
and visual effects pull off
uh for uh
for what we do it's just uh yeah i've
been in the business almost 30 years and
it still blows me away the virtual stuff
you did on this movie
it's really incredible how much from
what you did on this are you planning on
taking with you to future projects
because it does seem like you can go
anywhere in the world
you know if you do this right but i'm
just curious or maybe i'm completely
wrong well i think i'll always be more
of an organic filmmaker you know and
i'll lean into
i need to be inspired by a location i
need to be inspired by the
by the
you know touching and feeling and seeing
things and it's just you know there are
great filmmakers that can design out of
their vision in their head and then they
can create that vision in digital worlds
and and that's just not necessarily me
this is my first glimpse into that and
um i think every time i go out as a
filmmaker i've learned a new
you know i've learned skills you know i
home my comedic chops with deadpool and
like worked on sort of a comedy balance
and dramatic narrative on hobson shaw
and like
you know now i've taken away more of a
technical idea of this sort of visual
effects you know virtual production and
i'll use it i'll use it but at the heart
of me
is still the stump man choreographer who
goes to a location is inspired by that
fall potential or
goes to this location is inspired by the
arches here and i want to shoot them and
so i think um i'll always be that uh you
know i like talking about the editing
process yeah how did the film change in
the editing room as a result of friends
and family screenings or test screens um
[Music]
uh a lot and not a lot you know i think
we have i look it's our my long time
collaborator elizabeth ronald's daughter
you know her you know john wick um
atomic blonde you know deadpool and now
bullet train like she's amazing with um
with characters and i think we were
servicing
seven characters on this movie and like
making sure
obviously in the photography we had
gathered the arcs
um really beefy arcs and all the sort of
like thing the beats we wanted to hit
for every character but then that movie
is uh you know three hours long so then
you're like how do we distill this movie
just steal this movie get the pace keep
the momentum but still have these
satisfying journeys for these characters
and though
she's the master of that and he has
done it such a beautiful job with it um
but
i will say like the thing i learned from
deadpool and like comedy can really be
um
empirical you can test screen things and
you can learn and so i'm not
i love the testing process you can test
and hear people laugh
you know the joke works you can test and
peer people don't laugh you know the
joke don't it doesn't work
so
yeah the movie changes in post but um
again i think almost every scene in the
movie is there from the original script
but it's in it's distilled into the
essence of what it needed to be
for this so yeah it's changed but not
um tremendously from the project yeah i
mean
you make the movie three times that's
the cliche right you make it in you know
we had this vision for it in the script
then on set there's all these beautiful
beautiful you know magical moments that
happen momomon is created out of thin
air
during shooting and it becomes a
integral plot point and then you know um
then you get into post and you start to
play with the storytelling aspect and
the narrative and then it's made again
and it's made in its best form
and i gotta have a great collaborator
for that i think a lot of people don't
realize that you might have in your
assembly cut a five-minute scene and
that five-minute scene becomes two
minutes in the movie yeah but it also
has the essence
it has
at that point exactly what you need
and again um you know
tyka had made this comment recently like
you know i saw
for whatever it's worth i saw a headline
where he's like um i'm not into
directors cuts because they're director
cuts because they're bad or whatever
like that there's some truth to that
like you know there's a reason you go
through this process of distilling
distilling distilling the story and
making the journey as satisfying as
possible for the audience so completely
and i think there's a difference between
like uh kingdom of heaven the director's
cut which is three hours and it's a
masterpiece and the studio mandated two
hours and fifteen twenty minute version
that was really like there's differences
between yeah i mean that's not hard and
fast rule in any way yeah uh you know
much i enjoyed nobody i know you guys
are developing a sequel what what
exactly is happening with with a sequel
to that film oh i think everyone's
really excited about it everyone
involved is like you know full steam
ahead we um
are in the script process and i think um
you know we had so much fun making that
you know
you know kelly and i had a blast the
actors had a blast um the studio
loved the results and um
it's happening i mean i think it's
happening um
as fast as we can make it happen
well you know sometimes people talk
about sequels and like they never
actually happen do you think it's like
actually gonna happen
[Laughter]
yes i do i do because there are these
certain journeys that you go on and um
they're just undeniable experiences for
the people involved and that was one of
them and i think all of us want to go
back and and play in that universe and
and we want to see bob you know um bring
that character to life again i know
you're getting ready to do i mean you're
going from brad pitt to ryan gosling you
really it's a tough journey for you
all right
it's very tough um what what can you
tell people about uh fall guy which i
believe you're filming later this year
um i can tell you little i mean it's
sort of a it's a it's a reimagining of
the
the show from the 80s the late 70s early
80s uh lee major starring you know um
it's about a stuntman who
um
gets embroiled in some crazy drama
outside of the movie business that um
you know
and mayhem ensues
and so you know there's fun and action
and um we're trying to make a big summer
movie with it and universal is
incredibly supportive and ryan's been um
really collaborative uh on the material
and um we're starting
shooting in october and so we're in
we're in pre-production right now i
think one of the reasons why uh you can
have a lot of fun with fall guy because
it takes place in the movie world so you
can have a lot of cameos that feel
organic yeah like actual movie you know
to the world is that something you're
thinking about well i don't i mean
i think what we want to do we'll
definitely want to um have fun with the
the movie world i think again like for
all of us involved it's sort of like yes
it's about a stuntman so
whatever um
drama that's happening to this guy
it's like any other movie it's a great
world for that drama to be happening in
and then there's it's so rich with like
anecdotes from kelly's experiences my
experiences ryan's experiences you know
um
we're gonna we're definitely gonna have
a lot of fun playing with the um
the movie
our movie experiences inside of this
movie
i completely get it my last question on
bullet train so this movie is loaded
with action and as everyone knows or
should know action is not easy to film
it requires a lot of rehearsal
preparation and you know it's it's a lot
of work on which sequence or what day
did the cast basically come to you and
say [ __ ] off like this is too much you
know i'm joking around but you know what
i mean
um you know we had
as we do like you know ninety percent of
the action scene i mean you know we plan
every action scene and we choreograph it
and we do what we call stunt vis where
we shoot and edit it and i'm sure you've
seen it and you've probably posted
versions of it on your site where
the scene that was done with the stunt
guys and now here's the scene in the
movie and so we did all that for this
movie but there's still these times
where you're like inspired by something
and one of the fights um
with aaron taylor johnson and brad pitt
it it changed cars it turned out i
wanted i thought it was more fun to be
inside of the
like the um service car where the
concessions were like where the
concession cart could come in and we
could do this sort of um fun gag with
the concession girl problem is that set
wasn't made to fly the walls couldn't
move and
so logistically like
you got a camera operator in there you
got you got a china ball of light and
you got
sound and you're trying to like move and
fight and um you know
that was hard it was hard you know the
other places we really had prepped to
like create space move chairs like you
know now we're at this angle we have all
this breathing room over here but it's
gonna feel confined that was really
confined and uh the actors stepped up
and delivered and it was tough i mean
you know you're bumping your elbow on a
real piece of
furniture or you know
you're trying not to swing as far as you
can because the camera's right there
where it normally would be back a little
bit and so um
they did a great job and i i i kind of
threw them in the [ __ ] on that one but
they were
professional they did it that sequence
is great um i already got a wrap but
we'll talk more again uh next week at
imax yeah i look forward to it it's
gonna be great um hey have a fantastic
day man and congrats on the movie thank
you thank you
you